hello everyone to Samir from audio
science review I have another product
review for you a member requested that I
do it so here we are is the PS audio
power plant 3.
um if you've never heard of these
products the company calls them AC
regenerators and the idea is that you
can take AC that comes into the uh
outlet and the incoming IC socket in the
back converts it to DC and regenerates
it as a clean
Ace think of it as a as a amplifier that
can you instead of music you feed at 60
hertz or 50 hertz and it generates uh
you know high voltage output that's the
theory and that was true of the older
generation PS audio uh AC regenerators
this newer generation doesn't do that it
actually takes the AC input and augments
it with another waveform
has to clean it up and as you'll see
this has some ramification where the
performance actually reduced when it
does that
but anyway we're getting ahead of
ourselves uh this box is quite heavy
um it's 40 pounds so you can see it over
here it looks like a little box maybe
one and a half view vertically
rack unit and but uh it it's very hard
to pick up
um as I said it weighs 40 pounds or 18
kilograms and the reason for that is
there's a giant toroidal Transformer
inside
that really weighs it down
um not much controls in the front as a
matter of fact there are no controls you
just push this button and it comes out
of idle mode and it's active
the output light comes on and you can
change color and tell you there's an
overload it's got two features where it
can distort the waveform in two
different ways and supposedly that's
good for your system you can only access
them with the remote control there's no
way to make them do that with the unit
itself which is really poor design and I
didn't have the remote control so I
didn't test those two features
but the core selling point around this
box is is cleaner AC and we're going to
look at how clean they can make the AC
I got a kick out of the manual claim
that if you put an aftermarket cable AC
cable here you significantly improve
performance of it
which just boggles the mind if this is
supposed to clean uh generate a fresh
new AC that's extremely clean what on
Earth does it care about what the cable
is doing back here the whole point of it
is that it should be insensitive to the
AC input and and there here they come
and and tell you that it's very
sensitive to the AC in but and of course
they're ready and standing by to sell
you an expensive
AC cable to go with it I'll test it with
a cable that came with it was very thick
and heavy cable
despite the fact that this box can only
produce 300 volt amps roughly speaking
about 300 watts in reality if the power
factor is less than one
you get less than 300 watts but but
let's just go with that
um so for this 400 40 pound Behemoth uh
you only get 300 watts so this is only
good for Source devices no amplifiers or
anything like that on this thing
um it's got a switch in here where you
can put these two outlets and just sort
of filtered mode search protected mode
or uh
in which case you can then I guess plug
in amplifiers into it but otherwise you
put it in the regen thing and you get
six Outlets that are regenerated
as always I start with uh
showing the quality of the power that
that I'm getting on out of my own AC
outlet and
um to do that I have a what's called a
differential uh probe and it's got 101
attenuation so it takes what's very
dangerous 122 volts and brings it down
to just 1.2 volts and
um
it is differential meaning that it won't
pick up uh stray interference uh from
the air other equipment around here so
what we're looking at is a true waveform
that's coming out of my wall uh
ostensibly U.S the power is supposed to
be at 60 hertz but that would require a
perfect sine wave which power company
doesn't give you so instead you get that
60 hertz power but you also get all
these harmonic spikes and some amount of
noise in here that's built into this
so looking at over here again this you
gotta multiply the voltage by 100 oh
just step back what you're seeing is my
audio analyzer actually being used to
analyze power the advantage of that is
that you're seeing of extremely high
performance device measuring the power
60hz of course right in the audible
domain so it's exactly what the analyzer
is made for and it produces a type of
analysis that you never get even with
thousands and thousands of dollars you
could spend on power quality
instrumentation none of them have this
kind of resolution because we have a
very high Performance Audio analyzer
being used in here it tells you that the
frequency that's coming in is
59.9960s good enough for 60 hertz and it
says there's about 1.9 Distortion in my
waveform and you can see that you know
is there is my Peak here and you see all
these spikes are unwanted uh hard to see
today is actually when I measure this
was rather clean power and the Peaks
here are not that deformed but if you
square and you can see that maybe the
tops are flattened just a little bit so
an ideal waveform would look a little
bit cleaner than this
but two percent Distortion is hard to
see visually in the sine wave itself
so let's go ahead and and run the power
through the power plant 3 and see what
comes out of it we see that this
Distortion spikes are sharply reduce go
back up here you can see these things
going all the way up to -40 DB
now they're down to minus 50 DB so we
have 1002l DB reduction in here but a
strange thing happened or I shouldn't
say strange we saw the same thing with
PowerPoint 15 is that the noise floor
has actually gone up in the AC so uh if
you look in here we're at 80 here before
we're near 100 so we added almost 12 to
15 to 20 bits 20 DB of noise in there
and why is that happening because this
is an additive device as I mentioned
it's not the true AC regenerator it's
just an amplifier amplifying 60 hertz
and it has its own residual noise that's
now getting added to the AC away from
this AC Mains that's coming in
so the noise goes up if this was well
designed you wouldn't get any of this
indeed I have a AC Lab generator you
can't see it down here just that's the
instrument the instrument great one
costs the Same by the way 2500 and same
300 watts but it produces far cleaner
output uh in here I'm not showing it
here but it doesn't have any of the
problems of of this PS audio so as a
power regenerator this is actually not a
great uh device it's it could do far
better job cleaning a waveform and you
can see the two composite on top of each
other the red is my Mains spectrum and
blue is what the other PowerPoint 3 is
producing you can clearly see the noise
floor is is lower in in my Mains input
and got worse when someone threw this
box but the harmonic Distortion is
lowered and you know question is does
that matter but before we go there the
company advertises the noise is actually
eliminated
it doesn't just say reduce this is
illuminated whereas our finding shows
noise not only is not eliminated but
actually gone up this is why you want to
ask companies to prove their points uh
it's easy to say there's no noise just
because somebody thought in marketing
department that's what it does when it
doesn't actually work that way and
simple measurement here took me five
minutes to do shows that noise does not
reduced and if they had seen this and
maybe they would have spent time
cleaning up the noise floor of this
device but as we sadly see frequently
that companies don't measure their Gear
with respect to Performance and produce
things that probably a surprise to them
on this thing
um so that's what's coming into AC Mains
with the with power plant without but we
don't listen to AC right you don't plug
in your AC wire directly into your
speakers you destroy uh we power audio
equipment and to test to see what
happens to the audio equipment we have
to
um see the performance along we don't
have to but I'll show it along the way
so the first step is does a power supply
care uh an audio power supply doesn't
care about the clean AC or not so here
I've taken a linear power supply it's a
big giant block that comes with my grass
45C headphone measurement system so this
is a 14 000 system that comes with a
preamp and and
um that buffers the microphone input and
so I just use this power supply because
just sitting here convenient and it's
not so random thing so uh yeah take the
look at that and look at this spectrum
when it's powered directly by AC Mains
or when it's plugged into the uh PS
audio power plant we see that its
Spectrum doesn't change at all neither
noise or uh
harmonic Distortion is reduced uh why is
that because all this is actually
generated in the power supply itself the
power supply as a set of diodes that
rectify the signal and that causes uh
spikes that happen at that double the
main frequency usually so the spike yeah
120 hertz is actually a function of the
power supply itself it's not something
that came from the input and since it's
generated by the power supply it's going
to be output and above that we can see
very very clean Spectrum in here and now
you might say well you know do I have to
worry about this no because this is just
the incoming first stage of of DC Supply
in your equipment any High Performance
Audio device if it was designed around
this power supply we then take this and
filter it again and sometimes two or
three four times they filter it and
regenerate it using internal linear or
switching power supplies all this stuff
is just demolished down to nothing
um so can we demonstrate that that's the
case but before I go there let's just we
have proof that changing the input
harmonic Distortion as the power plant
does does absolutely nothing for your
power supply uh on this thing but again
we don't listen to the power supply we
listen to analog output of our devices
so I'd recently uh tested this shed
heretic uh preamplifier headphone amp
um I picked it for testing because it's
pretty cheap device uh forget how much
it is I think is uh 120 or so
um despite being 120 dollars extremely
high performance uh headphone amplifier
and you can see it's a dashboard over
here and look at it only has one
harmonic Distortion minus 130 DB
extremely low but importantly all the
power supply noise that we see are down
here in the minus 140 DB so with its own
power supply which is just this giant
Transformer brick uh it already has you
know incredibly lower
Mains noise and by the way we had uh
balanced out which doesn't have
we probably wouldn't see this either but
it's an unbalanced connection there's
stuff like that leaks from the power
supply
so we have a sign out of almost 120 DB
and two volts in we get two volts out
very clean sine wave so that's the as is
performance
which by the way is 5D better than 5 DB
better than threshold of hearing so no
way this thing has any audible
Distortion or noise whatsoever
so now we go ahead and connect it
through the power plant 3 and look at
what happened here you would have
expected a reduction in these things not
an increase right
um part if the 60 hertz increase could
be because there's a longer ground uh in
the system now because the power supply
is now plugged into this guy which then
has another wire that plugs into the
outlets so you've actually increased the
potential for getting harm and ground
Loops by deploying the power plant 3 or
by the way any device like it if it has
its own power supply you're asking for
trouble because here in another place
where the ground potential could be
different than your audio equipment and
cars basically it's like water in a pipe
you tilt it up more flows that way and
more in this case means more noise but I
couldn't figure out why the 180 Hertz
has gotten worse that's a function of
the rectifiers inside the device either
way we actually have a solid measurable
degradation with PowerPoint three of 2D
maybe now of course it's still above
below threshold of noise so it goes from
inaudible distortional noise to
inaudible Distortion and noise but it is
damaging this the performance of a
device
which I'm sure nobody intuitively would
know and I wouldn't even know I would
have thought at best you know at worst
would be passed through would make no
difference and but here we actually get
2 DB Wars and we can see exactly why
it's going to the divorce we actually
have uh power supply that spikes they're
actually as tall as our Distortion Spike
now whereas before you look at how much
lower they were from compared to our one
and only third harmonic here so we make
things worse uh on this thing uh people
keep talking about how we can't measure
the impact of AC we actually can we see
how trivial he has done this whole thing
didn't take much to uh to test and show
now usually you know I could stop here
and most of you watch this channel it
would be satisfied that this device uh
you know it does nothing useful and uh
best and worse could screw things up but
people always say did you listen to it
so I said fine I'll listen to it so I
built a very very high performance chain
uh using headphones which is my rme ADI
2 Pro it's an audio interface has ADC
and DAC that's my everyday desktop unit
listen to music through I use that as
the source that went to a topping A90
which is sitting on my desk always for
headphone testing and uh
and so that was the top in 890 another
very high performance source and then it
drives these uh Dan Clark expense
headphones or about four thousand
dollars headphone so all in all you have
about a six to seven thousand dollar
thing it's not it's just it's expensive
there's these hateful headphones are
extremely low Distortion probably the
best one I've ever measured this one and
the closed version of it and
um being headphones you get the uh you
know trans Series right next to your
ears you're able to crank up the volume
and here to you know slightest amount of
uh difference so please don't say
speakers are better no they're not
better because you got the room noise
and and room modes and everything else
uh all critical listening and audio is
actually done with headphones unless
we're dealing with uh speakers because
we're checking speakers anyway
I listened to this uh so what I did was
uh the um I took the transformer for the
shed uh uh preamp uh uh sorry for the uh
uh the step back the topping a 90 uh
power cable and uh plugged into the raw
outlet and then pulled it out and
plugged it into the power plant I
specifically picked an analog device
like the A90 if you pick a deck it has
to re-initialize and Playback stops and
everything with this the playback
continues so you're just quickly picking
it up and the sound Fades out and it
comes back up when you plug it in so I
went from the wall outlet to PS audio
and immediate impression was oh
something changed I don't know what
changed so the volume a little different
or sound but a little different and then
I plugged it back I unplugged it plugged
it back to Mains same impression oh
something changed you know it was a
detailed difference or not so bottom
line is that the fact that you're just
switching things causes you to received
there's a change when in reality there
was not I mean if I just listened to it
for a few more seconds
that impact of Change Would Disappear
With both and it sounded wonderful
whether I had it you know plugged into a
raw Outlet or plugged into power plant
three so I'm not surprised that nobody's
reporting that power plant 3 screwed up
their sound
and based on my testing unless you hear
some audible noise it can't do that so
can those people report oh my gosh you
know it you know soundstage got better
and all that stuff none of that happened
except for very subtle amount of it for
me because I was making an A B test when
you do that you pay attention
differently your brain actually is is in
control of your hearing and you can
change the gain and the perception of
what you hear is actually a feedback
loop and when you want to do something
you're commanding your hearing to
actually work differently and in these a
b tests you are gonna hear or perceive
the difference because you hear also the
function of a change it's a variable
device it's not a fixed instrument so if
somebody wants to claim that these
things do improve things all you gotta
do do the a b switch
have somebody else do it you don't look
at what the AC cable is do that 10 times
if nine out of 10 times you can even
identify which one's playing let alone
which one's improving I'm pretty sure
you won't find the difference so
um you know bottom line is this that
first the marketing claims are wrong
um this device is not an AC regenerator
it's an AC augmenter or fixer
it generates noise in my testing maybe
some wrong my testing I'll welcome the
company to go do their own and so it
doesn't
um on this thing but the noise that it
generates below threshold of hearing in
the setup that I have so I don't expect
anybody to hear a noise what I do expect
to happen is that your back will be sore
like mine is from carrying this thing
everywhere 40 pounds is quite heavy this
is the size of a weight of a linear
power up you know Class A B power I'm
pretty powerful one to be 40 pounds and
of course your pocket by twenty five
hundred dollars and have them forbid you
one bought a thousand dollar cable to go
with it if you've done all that just do
yourself a favor run a blowing test
since it doesn't change the volume or
anything it's very easy to do do an A B
test you just have to like I said
alternate the cable and see if you can
tell the difference if you can turn on a
video camera turn on your phone and
record it take notes so what you did
repeat 10 times and post it someplace so
we can look at it without you know be
happy to duplicate your tests and see if
it's right but nobody's ever come true
with with this kind of thing so bottom
line uh just it's a waste of money and
waste of resources engineering resources
and if you care about the planet and
environment you know the waste there
that's smart Engineers should be put
towards building amplifiers or something
else then they go build you know AC
regenerators every audio device you have
assumes AC is dirty and converts to the
DC and cleans it up to use it if they
don't you don't get these kinds of
performance you're just not going to get
such clean look noise floor and
distortion okay hopefully you got
something out of this video I'm sorry
it's a negative one for the next one
I'll do a positive review of the product
okay see you in a future video bye-bye